Virginia postural trimming had the
Atlanta well originally I'm from North
Carolina but actually grew up in South
Carolina so I grew up in Greenville
South Carolina and spent my childhood
and teenage years there I carry a few
sort of interesting and in some ways
unexpected things from my childhood one
is that I grew up in greenville in the
deep south in the 60s and 70s and my
parents while they were not activists
they were supporters of the civil rights
movement at a time that that was an
unusual position to take and one thing
that I learned from them I realized in
my adult life was how to be both a
dissident different and also very
mainstream at the same time because they
were very embedded in their local
community they were not alienated from
it they were not weird in any way but
they had these very different views and
that that's something in that particular
case it was the civil rights movement
and obviously growing up in that era in
that place issues of race are issues
that can they don't inform they're not
at the center of my work but they inform
my background and who I am somewhat but
the real thing that I learned from them
was about being different but also
mainstream as opposed to having to see
yourself as sort of an alternative or
being alienated from the general culture
at the same time growing up there and
having the personality that I have and
be female and being very sort of
assertive and intellectual I was very
elevated for the local culture and so I
was very happy to leave I have to say
with all due respect to the fine people
of Greenville um and so that's that's
another thing another aspect is that
it is the buckle of the Bible Belt my
family is a liberal but devout
Christians I come from my grandfather
was a Presbyterian minister I come from
very church-going background I am NOT
myself especially religious and I also
converted to Judaism in my early adult
life oh so I'm very different from that
but the fact that i grew up in that
culture that i really know the Bible
that I really know what it's like to be
a religious person who is a actual
believer where it informs at every
aspect of their life and to live in a
culture where that's normal is another
thing that I carry with me into my life
in the sort of public realm and then
finally and the one that most directly
informs my work is that I lived in a
poor place at a time that it was
experiencing economic growth and you
know the us-south if you go back to
right after World War two it's basically
sort of like a rich third-world country
I mean it would be you know and it has
the fact that is not poor today is
really quite a miracle of economic
development and and people who are from
the south I think appreciate the
benefits of just material prosperity
more than sometimes people in other
parts of the country and they also see
the economic progress that has taken
place in this country over the past 20
30 years that sometimes the rest of the
country doesn't recognize it and
particularly sort of the intellectual
class concentrated in New York LA very
expensive cities doesn't recognize how
much economic progress
Oh